[Music]
welcome back to p on I'm joined by my
Pac now the founder of within our
lifetime Nadin kiswani and the
broadcaster and journalist Emily Austin
okay Emily what did you make of that
exchange I just had with Loki I just
dislike how you ask a clear clear-cut
question and the question never seems to
be addressed on any of your interviews
quite frankly it seems like they use the
air time as an opportunity to deny the
question and just spread their own
narrative and it just it's it's
pointless the debate is pointless it's
it's a one-sided conversation and
there's no actual conversation it's
here's my question oh but what about
this pin right I mean n my problem with
it was I've interviewed some Pro
Palestinian voices in the last two weeks
who were emphatic immediately let me
make it clear what happened on October
the 7th was a disgusting terrorist
attack an Abomination and then they go
on to talk about the plight of the pal
inian people and maybe the historical
conflict and so on and I have great
respect for people that do that I've got
to say I really struggle with anyone who
just cannot have the humanity to start
by saying what happened on October the
7th was appalling an outrage do you feel
it was I think Palestinians are tired of
that being the starting point constantly
when right now there are 6,000
Palestinians who have been killed in
Gaza over 2500 of them children 33
mosques leveled Hospital level so we're
tired of that being the the main goal of
the conversation the main goal it's the
starting point of this war but hang on
it's the starting point of this war it's
not the main goal of what I want the
conversation to be the starting point
was when 750,000 Palestinians were
ethnically cleansed were expelled from
their homelands uh during the neba which
my grandparents which my
grandparents uh fled Palestine because
of the neba because of the massacres and
the rapes that they heard so to me
that's the starting point that's my
experience let's go with that for a
minute let's start with the knba because
the only knba is the part that people
forget to address 1948 after the
partition plan the Jewish State called
in the Arabs to live prosperously and
peacefully in the land but what happened
the very next day not even 24 hours
later is the alleged nakba where the
Arab leagues declared war on the Jewish
state that we just agreed to have our
two-state solution and what did they
tell their people leave the state let us
get the land back let's ethnically
cleanse the Jewish people and once we
defeat in this war you will come back to
the land so the only knockout was a
catastrophe that you guys the Arab
leagues waged a war that you could not
win and that is why I'm sorry your
grandparents had to leave their homes
that's completely ahistorical I don't
represent the Arab League I'm
Palestinian and I'm speaking on behalf
of the Palestine why do you find it hard
to just start given this war this latest
War that's erupted began with a terror
attack on October the 7th why is it hard
to not just say that was terrible I
don't see you asking reg if he condemn
the slaughter of innocent civilian she
can't do it can you no she can't because
she's the same woman who said every
Zionist before they die she' hear pop
pop before they die so she probably
agrees with the massacre so why would
she condemn them I think we're the media
is part of manufacturing consent we're
talking about you I'm speaking here and
I don't I'm not interested in speaking
to genocide deniers the media is
manufacturing consent for genocide
against the Palestinian people just like
they did with the LIE of the weapons of
mass destruction that was used to
justify the murder of over a million
Iraqis and there's been many lies that
have been repeated all over the news
including on your show where CNN had to
resend and even you said in subsequent
interviews about the 40 beheaded babies
I haven't seen a single shred I have not
seen a single shred of evidence about
these accusations coming out actually I
was actually deliberately
misquoted you raised an interesting
point there about this issue of the
beheaded babies from the October 7th
terrorist attack I was accused by Bassam
MF of saying on there that 40 babies had
been beheaded I never said that I said
there were reports that 40 babies had
been killed and that some had been
beheaded that appears to have been borne
out by other reporting but I haven't
seen the full details of every single
casualty so I don't know for sure I
certainly never said 40 babies were
beheaded but that clip has gone around
the world and I've been bombarded with
abuse based on an absolute lie I see a
big difference between saying 40 babies
were beheaded versus maybe uh you know
some you don't think 40 and some because
at the same that's that's the it's being
used to kill 6,000 Palestinians in okay
well let me ask Emily all right let me
ask Emily with this question I've asked
uh Nadine can she say she was horrified
by what happened on and and she she will
not say that which I think is very
disappointing would you in return when
you look at what's been happening in
Gaza in the last two weeks do you find
that appalling that the loss of young
lives of babies of children of women
innocent people who had nothing to do
with the terror attacks absolutely 100%
any death of innocent civilians should
be condemned privately and publicly and
I cannot believe I have to say that so
yes every children that is being
collateral damage every woman that's
becoming collateral damage my heart
aches for them why why can't you do that
I think we all agree that the loss of
innocent life is sad but I believe that
the loss of innocent life wouldn't be an
issue Israel didn't ethnically cleans
Palestine to begin with in 1948 that is
the source of this to me I go to the
source of the issue what happened on
October 7 isn't the beginning of of what
you okay ask me that's not the starting
why don't you ask me what do I think of
that you have a lot of preconceived
views of what you think I think I agree
with you I think the displacement of
hundreds of thousands of Palestinians in
1948 is the root cause of all of this
well you can think the Arab leagues for
declaring war on the solution there are
Myriad people at fault in the next 7
years cleed from our land it's not like
Jewish people were ethnically cleansed
from the land of Palestine they
colonized it from other I'm actually
discussing with him I refuse to speak to
genocide Den I ref's not a genocide
denier she's not you know the definition
of a genocide no I do know the
definition of a genocide currently is a
concentration camp because the
Palestinian you think Hamas W is
genocide I believe that look at the
numbers look at the Palestinians who
have been Ked ham St to talk about any
specific the people the Jewish people
it's their stated purpose the first
thing that we should be Lally
Palestinians to be returned home to
their Homeland literally specific H
stated purpose is literally the def
definition of genocide it's wiping out
people Bas who were released had
otherwise to say out of 250 let's
applaud Hamas you can't okay the
hostages that Israel didn't even want to
take begin with they didn't even want to
take them but they did take them the
Palestinians need to divorce they bom as
they bomb
risking their own
hostages needs to be liberated from
Hamas because when you're govern
governing body is a terrorist
organization that is the root of the
problem not the alleged ethnic cleansing
ethic cleansing of Palestine happened
decades decades before Hamas was even
created let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question do you think that
Hamas should stay in power in Gaza I'm
not here to talk about political
organizations no I don't care about
these questions because my people are
being ethnically
because I see the faces of 2,500
Palestinian children on social media
every day charred mutilated having
chemical weapons against them so this is
going to be my priority on this show
just like any Palestinian around the
world is speaking up for our you also
you also stop using babies as human
Shields stop most densely populated
region in the world you also know 2.1
2.3 million half of them are homeless
let me respond to you this is a
ridiculous respond to my question is
whether you think it is good for the
Palestinian people that Hamas stay in
charge given the scale of the terror
attacks They carried out given the
inevitable response that's come from
Israel with the inevitable loss of
Palestinian lives given the displacement
now of hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians out of the north of Gaza
into the South and who knows what's
going to happen the devastation to Gaza
and to gazan people has been
unbelievable and yet entirely
predictable once Hamas decided to carry
out the terror attack on the scale they
did I simply ask you do you do you think
that's a good thing for Palestine not
predictable that there will continue to
be resistance to oppression as long as
apartheid occupation ethnic cleansing
genocide continues to exist whether
Hamas exists or not is an irrelevant
question because as long as oppression
against the pales Palestinian people how
can you end that oppression as you see
it and many would agree with you why do
we address the oppression first she
called Israel an aparti state so I'd
like to just Define what apartheid is it
is segregation like what South Africa is
facing but the alleged aparti is because
Israel set up security measures after
the numerous uh bus bombings in 2000 and
set up checkpoints which they got very
insulted by but it's the same way that
airports now require security after 911
reasonably so so it is taking security
precautions secondly we have three Arabs
and if I'm not mistaken Muslims
currently sitting in the knesset does
that sound like a parts side let me
quote the Israeli defense minister and
how they view Palestinians he said that
we are fighting against human animals
that our soldiers will not be
accountable for anything there will be
no fuel no food no water and Gazza will
cease to exist this is what yav Galant
the Israeli defense minister has said
this is how they refer to I think one of
the big problems I think I think one of
the big problems leading up to this has
been that's not a PTO that let me just
say I think that's language ofing and
genocide Beyond part let me make the
point I want to make which is I think
one of the problems leading up to this
is that Benjamin Netanyahu for political
expediency to remain in power has packed
his cabinet with a bunch of right-wing
Headbangers who rhetoric at actually was
incredibly incendiary and Incredibly
unhelpful so I do think that actually
and you're you know what even if you're
right unfortunately the The Narrative
that it's about the land I'm sorry the
heavon massacres in 1927 1929 that was
not about Israel it is about the murder
of Jews all over the world National
Jihad day that I had to worry about
being in Manhattan last Friday was not
about is the day where we had a protest
where thousands of New Yorkers came out
that's not a national day of
Jing
for her life who was killed in America
what who was killed a 6-year-old
Palestinian boy was killed in Chicago 2
Wasing 26 times you're talking about
being afraid for your life I'm
constantly afraid for my life as a
Palestinian I can say to those examples
you just gave they are appalling
appalling but I also find it very
dispiriting that you can't just take a
moment to say what happened to the
people in Israel on October the 7th was
all so appalling but it came out of her
mouth she wants the zionists dead so how
is she supposed to condemn it it would
not have happened had Israel not
initiated this and you know this from
the beginning I think we always need
Israel did nothing that warranted what
happened October the 7th nothing Israel
nothing the scale of that terror attack
it's like saying that America brought
911 on itself I remember people saying
that in the streets after and that was
that equally repellent to me a terror
attack is a terror attack is a terror
attack what Hamas did that day was
unconscionable anyone with
announce anything that Palestinians do
to defend themselves will always be
categorized as a terrorist attack
because this is the position that the
world has put us in I'm responding to
your questions I have question when was
the last time Palestine had full
sovereignty over the land give me a date
or even a year that Palestine had their
own government going to engage with
genocide if you want to make a for me
she wants to be a child how are you an
attorney God can you ask her when did
Palestine have full sovereignty over the
land I you're taking talking point from
her you don't want to talk to me he to
do you want to answer me and stop being
a child if you have a Jew in court are
you not going to represent them as an
attorney this has nothing to do with
Jewish people actually have Jewish
people protesting on the streets of New
York pal not all shout out of each other
but it has everything to do with Jewish
people when hamas's stated intent is to
wipe Jewish people off the face of I'm
not the spokesperson of Hamas should to
this conversation that's all your
talking about no I'm here to flip the
narrative and make sure that this
government is funding Israel to the tune
of $10 million a day 3 million a year
and they're asking for an additional $14
billion in Aid the bombs that are being
manufactured by us companies are what's
being dropped on the world is watching a
genocide happening and is not doing
anything about it so the most important
thing for me to do right now is to stop
this genocide and questions about Hamas
are not going to do that it's condemning
the genocide of the Palestinian people
and condemning the UK and US governments
that we live under that I pay taxes to
that are killing Palestinian people
every day and the UN already said that
GZA would be unlivable by 2020 the UN
had already said uh that most of the
most of the hospitals um in Gaz
two-thirds of the health care facilities
um are not being able to provide yeah
are not able to to function so it's not
just the air strikes and the missiles
that are going to kill people the
blockade has been killing people and
will continue you should be able to say
that that is all wrong which I believe
it is wrong and you should also be able
to say that what happened October the
7th was wrong a human a human being who
cares equally about the lives of all
human beings would be able to say that I
care about the lives of all human beings
equally and that's why exactly I believe
that in order to preserve human life you
must end The Siege on G you must end the
blockade you must end the settler
colonization of Palestine listen it's a
it's from it's a passionate it's a
passionate debate and I understand why
emotions run High I appreciate you both
coming in thank you very much indeed
come back let's continue the debate we
only get you only get to peace in these
things I can promise you by thrashing
these things out people that hate each
other have to come together and they
have to try and find places of
compromise otherwise you never get to
peace 70 years this has been going on 70
years you need Justice to get peace you
need Justice and you need compromise and
you need both sides to a knowledge when
bad things happen you can say that is
unacceptable on October the 7th if any
tiny part of you says that was not was
that was acceptable or there's a reason
for it I can't have that but thank you
for coming in I appreciate it thank you
both very much indeed